this episode of the y-files is brought
to you by aura
early in the morning of January 4th 2012
a strange message appeared on the
internet just a few lines of text on a
black background posted anonymously
hello hello we are looking for highly
intelligent individuals to find them we
have devised a test there is a message
hidden in this image find it and it will
lead you on the road to finding us hello
we look forward to meeting the few that
will make it all the way through good
luck 3301
many speculated that it was a recruiting
tool for the NSA the CIA MI6 or even the
Masons but who was really behind this
and what was its purpose and did it even
have a purpose whether it did or not it
didn't matter because when you post a
puzzle on the internet looking for
highly intelligent people that's a
challenge that's simply impossible to
resist so the hunt for cicada 3301 was
on
[Music]
yeah he's got about six months left on
his contract and I wanted to see if
there's a way that I can get him out
sooner
foreign
a lot of complaints about him
[Music]
let me call you back
Chris um
hang on hello you have reached the great
goldini good afternoon Mr Moriarty this
is Susan with best Bowl solar I'd like
to offer you a free quote for solar
panels for your bowl you can save dozens
of dollars per year nope I don't know
when I rent take me off your list where
was I okay uh Gertie and I are at Magic
Camp magic Camp oh yeah I need to
practice my hang on hello you have
reached the great goldini this is the
IRS you owe back Texas we need you to
send us three Best Buy gift cards or
we'll have to arrest you can't be me I
don't pay taxes taxes are theft oh
so I'm working on my
mic press to digitation
Camp to perfect my sleight of Finn and
I'm trying to get Gertie to hold still
for the Saudi assistant half trick I
gotta find a way to hide that hump yeah
I don't know if there's a way
I don't think so but yeah
save the way
[Music]
I think a small donation today
absolutely not my uncle Horus spent 10
days trapped in the belly of a whale and
now wherever he swims he has to keep the
lights on so you take your wheels and
stick them right away sorry sorry no no
thank you take me off your stupid list
now immediately right this second you
sick son of it whoa this is ridiculous
you need to get Aura they can stop all
these spam calls all right buddy
sponsoring us again
yep Aura can identify data Brokers that
are selling your info and submit opt out
requests on your behalf so I could stop
answering all these stupid phone calls
you can and Aura does a lot more than
protect you from Robo calls you can set
up antivirus VPN password management
identity theft Insurance all from one
easy app with one affordable price hey
hey does it have a parental controls for
the Guppies one of my boys just turned
13 and I I don't want him checking out
the ladies and only things yeah Aura has
parental controls so go to aura.com the
Y files or click the link in the
description to get a free two-week trial
all right.com I got it I'll do it right
after we figure out how to get Grody out
of this sword assistant in the half box
oh we kind of have a hump stuck in a
head hole situation
yeah you're probably not okay baby is
your daddy you'll make it all better all
right I gotta go find my camel Lube what
is camel lube and why do you have it you
don't
[Music]
work here we go go Genie out
am I still here you are
goldini
[Music]
yep
still yes all right I'm gonna need a few
more days of magic Camp to work on that
you're supposed to be here this week
okay
on January 4th 2012 the first puzzle was
posted on 4chan by a self-identified
group called 3301 the post was simply an
image with text
there is a message hidden in this image
find it and it will lead you on the road
to finding us
the puzzle was open to anyone and
everyone as you solve each clue you move
on to the next level the image that was
posted on 4chan was the first clue
solvers tried various methods to extract
The Secret Message some use Photoshop to
view the pixels they apply different
filters and techniques to see what could
be hidden in the image but the solution
to the puzzle wasn't visual it was plain
text when an image is opened in a text
editor it looks like nonsense strings of
characters and symbols but to a computer
these symbols make sense it's a binary
format representing pixel placement
color information metadata and all kinds
of other stuff and when the 3301 image
was opened in a text editor there was a
string of characters at the end of the
file
because of the repeating characters and
the name Tiberius Claudius Caesar people
quickly and correctly guess the message
was encoded with a Caesar Cipher a
Caesar Cipher works by Shifting the
letters of the alphabet a fixed number
of places down or up you choose a shift
value for example three and for each
letter in the original text replace it
with the letter that's located three
positions down if you reach the end of
the alphabet you wrap around to the
beginning for example using a shift
value of 3 a becomes D B becomes e c
becomes F and so on the Caesar Cipher is
easy to crack with modern methods and
isn't considered secure but it's
historically significant and often used
as a basic introduction to cryptography
such was the case with the first puzzle
when the message was decoded with a
shift of four places the result was a
URL which turned out to be another image
whoops decoys this way looks like you
can't guess how to get the message out
the participants hit their first wall
opening this image in a text editor
showed nothing turned out that the image
contained two key words that hint at how
to get the real message out the words
guess and out those keywords indicated
you needed to run the image through
outguess a small application used for
steganography throughout this
complicated scavenger hunt our guests
would become a favorite tool of cicada
3301 now steganography is hiding a
message image or file within another
message image or file unlike encryption
which scrambles data so that it's
unreadable without the correct key
seganography conceals the fact that a
secret message exists at all imagine you
have a digital photo and you want to
hide a text message in it you could
subtly change the color values of
certain pixels to encode the text to
anyone looking at the image it appears
normal but someone who knows where and
how to look could extract the hidden
message Outkast revealed a page on
Reddit and a different clue a book
Cipher book ciphers are almost
impossible to crack without the book but
3301 knew how to give us just enough
information to keep us hooked and people
were hooked so when solvers finally made
it to Reddit they realized that cicada
3301 was just warming up
foreign
Ed a URL and a book Cipher a book Cipher
is a type of encryption where the key to
deciphering the code is a specific text
such as a book or article each word or
letter in the secret message is replaced
by a coordinate that points to its
location in the chosen text for example
if the word apple is found on page 42
line 5 word 3 of the book you'd replace
Apple in your message with the
coordinates
4253 the Beale ciphers are a set of
three ciphertexts that supposedly reveal
the location of 43 million dollars of
hidden treasure somewhere in Bedford
County Virginia they were first
published in 1885 and the second text
was actually decoded using the
Declaration of Independence the other
two texts are still a mystery but over a
hundred years later people are still
looking at 43 mil keeps you motivated it
does
so to decode 3301's book Cipher will
need the book which could be found on
Reddit but when you got to the page on
Reddit it was full of posts with
encrypted titles there was also an odd
image in the header even the page had a
title that looked like random characters
but by now everyone knew there was
nothing random about it there were also
several lines of texts and two
additional images using out guests on
the welcome mat image gives us this
from here on out we will
cryptographically sign all messages with
this key it is available on the MIT key
servers patience is a virtue good luck
3301 this information was extremely
important to the people following the
clues there were a lot of imposters
popping up pretending to be cicada 3301
but because 3301 implemented pgp
encryption new messages could be
authenticated pgp stands for pretty good
privacy and this is an encryption system
used for sending emails and sensitive
files how it works is you create two
keys one is public which you share with
everyone the other is private which only
you have so if someone wants to send you
a secure message they encrypt it with
the public key that you shared and then
you use your private key to decode the
message 3301 would encrypt all their
Clues going forward like the clue hidden
in the second image which was a
stereogram which is an optical illusion
that creates a 3D image when viewed in a
specific way this stereogram kind of
look like the holy grail and this image
also contained a secret message
the key has always been right in front
of your eyes this isn't the quest for
the Holy Grail stop making it more
difficult than it is good luck
3301 Holy Grail subreddit also contained
many lines of what appeared to be
encrypted text the question that
everyone faced was which Cipher method
had to be used and how do you find the
key the hidden message provided a hint
the key was literally in front of your
eyes it was the image in the header
those symbols are actually Maya numbers
the title translates too
what are you talking about the clue I'm
gonna solve this one okay what is it
yeah that's uh
right
I'm word for goat kiss now the letters
make up a
reminder for lettuce no they make up a
lion
no it's a key it's not a Mayan word it's
an encryption key okay okay don't get
your panties in a wad ah key to what
remember the subreddit was full of posts
with encrypted titles it was determined
that they were encoded with a visionaire
cipher which is another letter shifting
encryption technique visionaire encoded
text needs a key the string of letters
made from the Mayan numbers was that key
without the key decoding a visionnaire
encrypted message is almost impossible
even with the key it would take a long
time and if you missed just one letter
you end up with meaningless texts so
your translation has to be perfect but
there's no reason to do it manually it
takes a lot of processing power but
computers can eventually guess most
visionnaire keys but if you already have
the key computers can easily decode the
message there are even websites to help
you do this the decoded text was from
Thomas bullfinch's mythology this was a
classic work based on the tales of King
Arthur the Knights of the Round Table
and their hunt for the Holy Grail so now
the solvers knew the book that was
needed to decode the book Cipher but
this time it wasn't a message or a web
page or an image it was a phone number
at first people thought cicada 3301 was
just an online troll pumping out puzzles
to waste everyone's time but there was
just too much work put into it whoever
was behind the puzzles was someone with
computer skills and advanced knowledge
in cryptography so the duck image led to
a book code and a page on Reddit and the
page on Reddit led to two more images
Maya numbers and the book Cipher and the
book was about King Arthur's quest for
the Holy Grail
on with it yes get over there
now we can use the book code mentioned
in the outguest message from the initial
image a book code encodes each letter
with two numbers the line number and the
character index in the line by applying
the book code to the text we get the
following text string
call us telephone number
214-390-9608 when the book Cipher
revealed a phone number in Austin Texas
code Breakers thought they'd finally
learn who was behind cicada 3301
you have done well there are three prime
numbers associated with the original
final dot jpeg image three three zero
one is one of them you will have to find
the other two
multiply all three of these numbers
together at added.com on the end to find
the next step good luck goodbye no
answers just another clue cicada 3301
was a series of intricately woven
puzzles each puzzle got progressively
more complex but future puzzles often
referred back to earlier ones indicating
this entire process was thought out well
in advance the light of the scavenger
hunt also weeded out casual participants
only those with patience would continue
it was natural selection
solvers went back to the original image
looking for anything that would indicate
a prime number outgass revealed nothing
scanning the image with Photoshop and
other forensic tools also provided no
help people counted the characters and
the spaces in the text they converted
the characters to ASCII they ran the
text through every cryptography
algorithm you could think of and still
nothing but like many of the cicada
puzzles the answer was hidden in plain
sight the original image looks like a
square but Keen observers noticed it
wasn't a perfect square the image was
actually 509 pixels wide by 503 pixels
tall 509 and 503 are prime numbers
multiply 509 by 503 by 3301 and you get
eight four five one four five one two
seven added.com just like the voicemail
said and that's where we see the
infamous cicada image for the first time
under the image was a timer and it was
counting down when the countdown reached
zero the timer was replaced with a list
of coordinates 14 locations in five
countries all over the world with an
invitation to find the location nearest
you up until now the puzzles existed
exclusively on the internet but now
cicada 3301 was going out into the real
world
the list of 14 locations around the
world indicated that cicada 3301 was a
global organization or a handful of
people with the time and money to create
complex puzzles and travel the globe but
by taking the next round of puzzles into
the real world cicada created another
filter in order to move forward not only
did you have to be excellent at
cryptography you had to have the means
to travel to one of the locations
provided and only the most committed
could proceed at each of the coordinates
was a poster containing the cicada image
and a QR code scanning the QR code
resulted in a link to another JPEG file
like before running the image throughout
guests revealed secret text
a poem of fading death named for a king
meant to be read only once and vanish
alas it could not remain unseen
the image also included a warning
you've shared too much to this point we
want the best not the followers thus the
first few there will receive the prize
Good Luck Good Luck 3301 considering the
difficulty of the puzzles and the
Mystery surrounding them it was only
natural that people were talking and
sharing information and collaborating if
you didn't live near one of the cicada
locations you almost had no choice but
to ask for help but cicada 3301 was
clearly watching and if you got caught
teaming up you'd be out and it didn't
take long to identify the text referred
to by the last clue it was the poem
Agrippa by cyberpunk novelist William
Gibson Agrippa is a very cicada type of
poem it was originally distributed on
floppy disk and after you read the poem
it encrypted itself meant to be read
only once solving the book code resulted
in another URL but this one was
different a DOT onion extension onion
routing makes the data's source and
destination untraceable by encrypting
the data multiple times times like the
layers of an onion onion Pages aren't
accessible with a regular web browser
you need a specialized browser designed
specifically to access Pages hosted on
the onion router Network or tour Network
in other words the dark web
foreign
they imagine a Place full of illegal
activities a place where people can buy
and sell drugs weapons and worse and
it's true those things exist on the dark
web but that's only a small fraction of
what's there the dark web is actually a
part of the Deep Web which is all the
unindexed parts of the internet
including private databases email
accounts and subscription services in
fact most of the data on the internet
exists on the Deep Web the dark web is
specifically the section of the Deep Web
accessible only through specialized
tools like the Tor Browser which makes
web traffic Anonymous before it was made
public Tor was used by the US Navy to
secure government Communications later
it became a beacon for privacy Advocates
and anyone looking to Shield their
online activity from prying eyes
not just criminals though journalists
use the dark web to communicate with
activists in oppressive countries
whistleblowers have used the dark web to
remain anonymous if you want to remain
anonymous and untraceable you go to the
dark web it's only natural that a group
like cicada 3301 would end up there
so cicada solvers who made it this far
type the onion link into their Tor
Browser and were greeted with the
following message
congratulations please create a new
email address with a public free
web-based service one you've never used
before and enter it below we recommend
you do this while still using Tor for
anonymity we will email you a number
within the next few days in the order in
which you arrived at this page once
you've received it come back to this
page in append a slash and then the
number you receive to this URL
3301 congratulations this would be the
first time that cicada would communicate
directly with people very few made the
cut but those that did received an email
a few days later
this message will only be displayed once
here is a message that has been
encrypted with RSA the encrypted message
is a number break the decryption key
then come back to the same URL and enter
the decrypted message to continue
each person who has come this far has
received a unique message encrypted with
a unique key
you are not to collaborate no sharing
your message or key will result in not
receiving the next step Good Luck Good
Luck 3301 since each participant was
assigned a unique number cicada 3301 was
able to track who is sharing information
if you got caught you're out
hello hello you have shared your
information online you are now removed
from this all together fine even if you
crack the key you've been given it
doesn't matter
because you have demonstrated that you
can't be trusted to follow simple
instructions anyway thank you for your
participation to this point bye goodbye
3301 but those who were able to solve
the puzzle and solve it alone received
an email the email contained the
following text along with a piece of
music
[Music]
this song is your own path another stop
on the road toward Enlightenment follow
it and share not
[Music]
oh that was terrible
still better than K-pop
[Music]
the music was encoded as a midi file
midi is music expressed as code it was
found that there were two tracks that
provided two different messages each
message had fewer than 26 combinations
of pitch and tone which hinted that each
combination could represent one letter
the music was decoded into a cryptogram
which could then be broken
very good very good you have proven to
be most dedicated to come this far to
attain Enlightenment create a gpg key
for your email address and upload it to
the MIT key servers then encrypt the
following word list using the cicada
3301 public key sign it with your key
send the ASCII armored ciphertext to the
Gmail address from which you received
your numbers
everyone who received this email was
also given a set of 50 unique words
those words were to be encrypted and
emailed back what happened after that is
unknown but about a month later the
image on the subreddit changed
hello hello we have now found the
individuals we sought thus our
month-long Journey ends for now thank
you for your dedication and effort if
you were unable to complete the test or
did not receive an email do not despair
there will be more opportunities like
this one hello thank you all 3301 and
just as critically as the cicada puzzle
started it finally ended it was assumed
that the mysterious group whoever they
were finally found the highly
intelligent individuals it needed cicada
3301 stopped posting messages and was
largely forgotten but a year and a day
after the first puzzle was posted cicada
3301 was back
foreign
cicada was quiet for a year but on
January 5th a new image was posted to
4chan
hello again hello again our search for
intelligent individuals now continues
the first clue is hidden within this
image find it and it will lead you on
the road to finding us we look forward
to meeting the few that will make it all
the way through good luck
3301 right before running the image
throughout guests led to a book code
which led to a URL which led to a file a
large file
this file was its own mini operating
system
when you booted it up it displayed the
prime numbers up to 3301 and then
restarted the computer it would do this
indefinitely but there was also a
message within the numbers the key is
all around you good luck 3301
those numbers led to a Twitter account
that was posting tons of encrypted text
that nobody could decode
but on the mini operating system someone
realized that you could break the boot
sequence and browse the file system in
one of the folders there was a song This
Time an MP3 file
foreign
tags the title of the file was the
instar emergence solvers tried all sorts
of techniques on this file to search for
hidden meanings they played it backwards
they isolated frequencies they even ran
the sound through spectral analyzers but
they found nothing there were hidden
messages and odd mini poems all over the
place but nothing seemed connected then
someone determined that the messages
from the Twitter feed were actually
lines of binary code which could be
assembled into a file but it was
encrypted and nobody could figure out
how to decode it it turned out that the
messages were encoded with the binary
data from another file as the key that
file was the song
[Music]
so using the song the Twitter data was
decrypted into an image
a room table the room table image also
contains secret text which led to more
puzzles which led to the dark web and to
more posters around the world with
different coordinates in order to move
forward from here you need to have
solved every puzzle so far now on the
posters there were phone numbers and his
phone number required an access code
that you decipher using the room table
once you got past the access code a
computerized voice then read you a
string of letters and numbers which
turned out to be a hex code
and then the hex code converted to a
page on the dark web which had a test
for you to take
there are 19 questions in total some
mathematical some logical some
philosophical very few people made it
past this test but those that did
received an email
congratulations your testing has finally
come to an end congratulations we hope
you have enjoyed the vacation over the
last few weeks you will be very busy now
should you choose to join us you have
all wondered who we are and so we shall
now tell you we are an international
group we have no name we are drawn
together by Common beliefs but tyranny
and oppression of any kind must end that
censorship is wrong and that privacy is
in inalienable right
cicada 3301 was pretty well known by now
and was being connected to hacker groups
and this was addressed in that email
we do not engage in illegal activity nor
do our members if you are engaged in
illegal activity we ask that you cease
any and all illegal activities or
decline membership at this time we will
not ask questions if you decline however
if you lie to us we will find out
but the big question was why what the
cicada 3301 even do we are much like a
think tank in that our primary focus is
on researching and developing techniques
to Aid the ideas we Advocate Liberty
privacy security
and if you choose to accept membership
we are happy to have you on board to
help with future projects
so that was it cicada 3301 found a few
more recruits and went dark but the
following January people eagerly waited
to see if cicada would return and they
did not disappoint
[Music]
after being inactive for a year in
January 2014 the cicada Twitter account
tweeted a link to a new image
hello hello Epiphany is upon you good
luck your pilgrimage has begun good luck
Enlightenment awaits hello good luck
during the time cicada was quiet there
were lots of fake puzzles floating
around claiming to be from cicada 3301
and they all turned out to be fakes but
running this new image throughout guests
revealed a new message that proved to be
authentic cicada 3301 was back and they
followed their familiar format they
embedded messages and images that could
be extracted without guests these images
led to more clues on various web pages
and the dark web and a new piece of
music was also discovered this one was
called interconnectedness
[Music]
using some familiar techniques as well
as some new ones cicada solvers
concluded that cicada was focusing on a
single document
it's called the Libre Primus or first
book as more puzzles were solved more
pages of Libra premise were uncovered
the book was written using the runes
found in earlier puzzles but the
solution to every puzzle seemed to be a
clue to yet another puzzle
people went back to the music file they
found more clues from image files they
extracted more codes and more puzzles
like magic squares and anagrams
all of those were decoded to reveal
strange poems which were nothing more
than more clues Libra premise is 59
pages and only a handful have been
solved and the pages that are solved are
still mysterious January 2015 came and
went with nothing from cicada some
people speculated that cicada had enough
recruits for whatever it was they were
doing others thought that cicada would
stay silent until all of Libra premise
was solved and they could be right in
January 2016 cicada tweeted a link to a
new image running the image the app
guess proved it was authentic
hello hello the path lies empty Epiphany
seeks the devoted devoted Libra Primus
is the way its words are the map their
meaning is the road and their numbers
are the direction
seek and you will be found good luck
3301 beware false paths many speculated
that their numbers are the direction was
the major clue but still no progress was
made in 2017 a user stumbled across a
message from cicada in Google's cached
pages that nobody had noticed
beware false paths always verify pgp
signature 3301
and that was the last anyone heard from
cicada 3301 it's been a few years with
no solution to Libra premise and no
further contact from cicada this was
disappointing to a lot of people after
all this over several years we were
still no closer to finding out who
cicada 3301 was or what they did but
Liebert Primus was the third Quest the
first two were solved and the people who
solved them
they started talking
[Music]
when that first image appeared on 4chan
looking for highly intelligent
individuals the chase was on the
mysterious group known as 3301 presented
Clues and challenges that thousands of
techies and puzzle solvers found
impossible to resist each Mystery became
more complex the clues that connected
Julius Caesar and King Arthur to
cryptography were genius and easy enough
to solve that people became hooked the
solutions that led the phone numbers and
Geographic coordinates made the search
even more real but over time it became
clear that 3301 was looking for a
specific type of person to solve cicada
you needed knowledge of the concepts and
the tools used in encryption you had to
have computer skills understand
operating systems and be handy with
programming it also didn't hurt if you
had expertise in my numerology and
pre-christian literature yeah who
doesn't
but who was cicada a popular theory was
that this was a recruiting effort for a
government intelligence agency like CIA
NSA or MI6 there was plenty of precedent
for that during the second world war the
top secret government code and Cipher
School used crossword puzzles printed in
a Daily Telegraph to identify good
candidates for Bletchley Park those
recruits along with Alan Turing went on
to solve the Enigma machine which helped
the Allies win the war NSA and CIA ran
similar contests over the years
companies like Google and Microsoft have
also used cryptography and puzzles to
recruit but one of the early winners
said cicada was none of these
after solving the final round of puzzles
in 2013 he received an email with a
username and password along with a site
address on the dark web the site had two
parts a message board and a chat room
The Message Board had various topics
including a welcome section and an area
for cicada's goals and current projects
the chat room had about 20 members
according to a couple of the winners
cicada wanted to further the use of
cryptography so more people would have
access to Internet privacy
cicada had some big goals but in the
short term they wanted to recruit highly
technical people to develop open source
cryptography software all of that to
fight people to write free software yep
and I think this was cicada's big
mistake the recruits didn't want to
write software that wanted to solve
puzzles and when the puzzle stopped the
membership dwindled there were spikes in
membership when new challenges appeared
but it was the same story the winners
weren't interested in writing software
they weren't driven by ideology they
didn't care about politics they just
wanted to solve puzzles the same thing
happens when NSA CIA gchq and other
intelligence organizations do
recruitment drives many of the winners
are offered positions in one of these
agencies and many of them refuse they
don't want to work in government yeah
they're too smart to work in government
well that might be part of it but really
they just want to solve puzzles whenever
you achieve a task your brain rewards
you with a hit of dopamine this could
mean finishing a workout completing a
school project or figuring out an escape
room achieve a goal all get some
dopamine our brains love dopamine it
turns out that solving problems is one
of the biggest if not the biggest source
of dopamine for the brain solving
puzzles like those presented by cicada
reward us with dopamine while we're
working on them and when we actually
solve one well cicada solvers describe
that feeling as nothing less than
exhilarating now plenty of people are
interested in politics and ideology but
not too many of them would describe
their interest as exhilarating puzzles
make us happy when was the last time
politics made you happy and although two
of the goals of this channel are to
educate and Inspire the primary goal is
to entertain in other words the y-files
is here to make you happy so that's why
I've included a cicada type puzzle in
this video
think you can find it
foreign
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do us a favor like
comment subscribe share that stuff
really helps the channel and like most
topics we cover here today's was
recommended by you so if there's a story
you'd like to see or learn more about go
to the yfiles.com tips and if you need
more Wi-Fi's in your life check out the
y-files Discord it's free to join and
there's thousands of people on there and
special thanks to our patrons who made
this episode possible I couldn't do any
of this without you so from the bottom
of my heart thank you now if you'd like
to support the channel consider becoming
a member on patreon it's only three
bucks a month you get all kinds of perks
like early access to the videos with no
commercials and you get your name in the
credits check those out if you're not
much of a jointer maybe buy something
from the Wi-Fi store
[Music]
it's gonna do it until next time be safe
be kind and know that you are
appreciated
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
laughs
thank you
foreign
[Music]